الولايات المتحده تتبع عورات روسيا
العسكريه لتكشف عيوبها امام الجيش
الاوكراني
البانتاجون يخترق بعمق اجهزه الامن
والاستخبارات الروسيه وفق ما جاء في
الوثائق المسربه خطوه جعلت واشنطن قادره
على تحذير اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخططه
لها وتقديم تقييم لقوه اله الحرب الروسيه
ومنحتها فهما واسعا للتخطيط الروسي
وامكانيه تحذير حلفائها بشان عمليات موسكو
في المستقبل
الوثائق المسربه ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي
المتهاوي الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
بيانات اتاحت لواشنطن نقل المعلومات
الحساسه من اجل الدفاع عن نفسها من خلال
تحديد توقيت الضربات واهدافها بدقه في
حاله يرثى لها هكذا قيم الامريكيون الجيش
الاوكراني وفقا لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الوثائق تفصل نقص المخصصه للدفاعات الجويه
لدى الجيش الاوكراني كما تناقش المكاسب
التي تحققها القوه الروسيه حول مدينه
باخموت الشرقيه
القاده السياسيون والعسكريون في اوكرانيا
لم يكونوا بمعزل عن اعين التجسس الامريكي
وفق الوثائق المسربه ايضا
تحليلات قالت ان هذه الوثائق بامكانها
الحاق ضرر حقيقي بالمجهود الحربي
الاوكراني ان استطاعت موسكو قطعه مصادر
المعلومات
البيانات اظهرت ايضا ان فاجنر تعمل بنشاط
لتهديد المصالح الامريكيه واحباط مشاريعها
في افريقيا ومناطق اخرى
احدى هذه الوثائق كشفت ان مسؤولين من باك
نار التقوا سرا بجهات تركيه في فبراير
وبحثوا تهريب اسلحه ومعدات لاستعمالها في
اوكرانيا وفق ما نقلت صحيفه نيويورك
قالوا ان الوثائق تبدو صحيحه لكن ادخل
التعديلات على بعضها لعكس صوره افضل عن
الوضع الروسي لاسيما من خلال التقليل من
حجم الخسائر الروسيه بلال البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات